mais je trouve que ce qui gère la
communication de laetitia comme disait
benjamin ils sont super forts parce
qu'en deux jours ils ont retourné la
situation peut-être vous les connaissez
moi je les connais pas oui mais ils ont
retourné une situation compromise
personne ne pouvait personne ne pouvait
sentir laeticia hallyday ya quatre jours
et aujourd'hui elle redevient populaire
donc bravo à ces gens vivent de la com
vous fait pas moi j'ai fais une pression
[Applaudissements]
ça me fait ça me fait penser qu'il
faudrait que je marie sans tarder parce
que j'espère hamamura voir hollande ex
mari qui l'avait ex femme pour parler de
lui dans les médias
non monsieur c'est quand même très
important astaldi sortez sortez sortez
[Rires]
et puis son frère m'a fait les fous
furieux